resume 2019 you now resume has always
been what here's my job here's where I
work here's my degree here's this here's
that let me take what impresses me I'm
sitting there hiring different CFOs and
6ef boats are sitting there giving me
their pitch the guy at the end says the
following to me he says by the way I
watched some of your videos well I'm
here to tell you there's seven sign
there you're going to be successful in
life I just want you to know just last
week I ran a mile in 5 minutes and 42
seconds as he did what he said I ran a
mile last weekend 5 minutes and 42
seconds and I'm 46 years old I said you
got to be kidding me no I made a note of
it that's stuck with me when I stepped
away why I thought about his health
condition stamina energy to be able to
last long what does this mean to you if
I am applying anywhere today and I'm
posting my resume I'm gonna tell you
what I'm posting if I've travelled the
world I'm letting you know travel the
world because I've seen culture and I'm
gonna explain to you that I know how to
deal with different cultures if I have
contacts the right contact I'm gonna put
the five contacts that I have in high
places direct contact cell phone that I
have a relationship with influence if I
have a certain influence where my
following I'm gonna put on my resume
62,000 people follow me on Instagram you
know ninety three thousand people follow
me on Facebook I have 17 thousand
followers on Twitter and their main
niche is the following five words I'm
gonna put the books out breath here's
the top five books I've read in business
I'm gonna write it these are the top 10
books average I'm gonna sit and say this
guy's read these books yes Wow
I asked you about the book you know
about the book I'm impressed more than
your degree
I'm impressed the books you've read your
credit score I got a 793 credit score
huh this guy have a 793 credit score
credibility discipline your hell I ran a
marathon three weeks ago really which
one boston marathon 26.2 miles you ran
it yes I did an Ironman you know I
wonder CrossFit whatever whatever for
the state of Texas I'm impressed
those things today matter on your resume
maybe not 20 years ago today they do I
learned how you view resume
you